I call it "The
Toothbrush Helmet."
So my toothbrush
helmet is
recommended by zero
out of 10 dentists,
and it definitely did not
revolutionize the
world of dentistry,
but it did completely
change my life.
Since then, I've carved
out this little niche
for myself on
the internet
as an inventor of
useless machines,
because as we all know,
theeasiest way to be
at the top of your field
is to choose a
very small field.
To me that'sthe
true beauty
of making useless things,
because it's this
acknowledgment
that youdon't always know
what the best answer is.
And it turns off that
voice in your head
thattells you that you know
exactly how the
world works.
And maybe a toothbrush
helmet isn't theanswer,
but at least you're
asking the question.